this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by the curiosity stream
and nebula bundle deal now just 11 59
for an entire year until december 24th
i don't think it is very useful to
speculate on what god might or might not
be able to do
rather we should examine what he
actually does with the universe we live
in
all our observations suggest that it
operates according to well-defined laws
these laws may have been ordained by god
but it seems that he does not intervene
in the universe to break the laws at
least not once he had said the universe
going
in the cauldron of the early universe no
light could escape the dense opaque fog
of primordial gas
as this cosmic soup of atomic particles
began to cool down
hydrogen atoms began to form leading to
the universe's first bright violent new
stars
burning through the fog that once
blocked all light from escaping the
expanding universe
some of these early photons have
traveled unhindered through the vast
empty expanse of space for 13.5 billion
years and will reach their final
destination here on the man-made
detectors of the james webb telescope
a space odyssey coming to an end because
of the curiosity of humans
the james webb telescope is going to
give us our first detailed glimpse of
this early universe from which we
and everything we know was born
the james webb telescope is a 10 billion
dollar endeavor an endeavor that has
eaten into nasa's limited budget
consuming one quarter of nasa's entire
astronomy budget for years
and in the early hours of a tenuous
launch date of december 24th this 10
billion dollar gamble will launch aboard
the ariane 5 rocket a european heavy
lift launch vehicle from the european
spaceport kuru french guyana astronomers
physicists and enthusiasts alike will
look on with nervous excitement as this
rocket carries the next generation in
human curiosity
this is the insane engineering of the
james webb space telescope
the combination of technologies required
to make the james webb telescope
possible are unique to this time period
in human history
the launch vehicle the image processing
the electromechanical systems the
cooling systems the mirror and the
sunshield
this endeavor is the culmination of not
just decades of work from the engineers
and scientists at nasa but thousands of
years of work of our ancestors
the materials and engineering required
to peer back
13.5 billion years into the
re-ionization epoch are a punctuation
point in human history that we the human
race
should be celebrating and watching with
baited breath together
the launch will take place here in
french guiana a space port ideally
located on the earth's equator to give
the james webb telescope an extra push
towards its final destination
the james webb telescope will not be in
orbit around earth like hubble it will
be launching to a destination 1.5
million kilometers from earth lagrange
point two lagrange points are special
points in space where small objects like
satellites can stay more or less in the
same position relative to the
gravitational bodies that they are
traveling with
this happens because the gravitational
pull from the two bodies precisely
equals the centripetal force required
for the object to move with the
gravitational bodies like little parking
spots in space that allow satellites to
sit in a relatively stable position
while using a minimal amount of fuel to
stay there
there are five lagrange points between
the sun and earth l1 lies between the
sun and earth it's extremely useful for
sun observation satellites however the
nature of the james webb telescope's job
wants it to avoid the light from the sun
as much as possible because
it is an infrared telescope infrared his
heat and the heat emanating from the sun
would completely saturate its sensors
and make observing the cold distant past
impossible so
it will be launching to l2 located about
here here the telescope can turn its
back to the sun earth and moon which
will stay in the same position nicely
lined up behind the telescope thanks to
lagrange point 2's unique physics
in order to operate correctly the dark
side of the telescope needs to operate
at minus
233 degrees celsius
without a way to block out the heat from
the sun and earth the telescope would be
scorched at 83 degrees celsius
nearly hot enough to boil water
this is a huge amount of heat to block
and to do this the james webb telescope
will carry a massive shield on its back
like a tortoise
and making such a such a device
is a very very tough problem
that's mike minsel
mission systems engineer for the james
webb telescope
we had to map every heat flow to make
sure that we do not let any heat leak
through from the hot side to the cold
side
to make sure that that sunlight which is
dumping approximately 200 000 watts
of power onto onto the under the uh in
our direction
we only want less than about a watt of
that to make it through
to the telescope so that it passively
cools down to those temperatures
preventing that heat transfer is as mike
said a very tough job
heat can transfer in three ways
conduction where heat is transferred
from atom to atom in direct contact with
each other like heat traveling down a
copper pipe convection where heat is
transferred from the physical movement
of atoms and radiation where heat is
transferred by electromagnetic waves
in the vacuum of space convection isn't
a concern so that leaves conduction and
radiation as methods of heat transfer
let's see how the james webb telescope
is managing these
first material choice the shield needs
to be light strong resistant to
degradation from solar radiation
dimensionally stable across a range of
temperatures and reflective that's a
long shopping list of requirements and
captain a type of high performance
plastic manages to check all the boxes
each layer of the captain's sun shield
is incredibly thin
layer one the layer closest to the sun
is the thickest at 0.05 millimeters
while the next four layers are just
0.025 millimeters thick
captain by itself is actually
transparent which isn't a fantastic
trait for a sun blocking heat shield
thankfully the wonder material that is
captain can be easily coated in other
materials each layer is coated in a 100
nanometer thick coating of aluminium
giving the sun shield its reflective
appearance
this reflective quality helps prevent
heat transfer through radiation by
simply bouncing that radiation back to
space
and with the gaps between each layer the
heat that is absorbed can't easily
transfer through conduction or
convection taking advantage of the
highly insulating vacuum of space
between each layer
heat could still transfer between each
layer through radiation
the outermost layer will gain heat and
start glowing with infrared radiation
just as we see through an infrared
camera
in order to prevent this the sunshield
has some clever engineering designs
the layers are angled relative to each
other to ensure the reflected radiation
between each layer is funneled outwards
to space
ensuring that each layer gradually
reduces the temperature as it gets
closer to the critical components in the
instrument bay the layers gradually get
smaller in area from layer 1 through 5
ensuring the mirror only has a direct
line of sight with the coldest layer at
all times
layer 1 itself is also coated in a
special silicon coating 50 nanometers
thick giving it this pink appearance
silicon was used because it has high
emissivity simply meaning it emits a lot
of energy it absorbs out as thermal
radiation
meaning the material will not hold onto
its heat which would give it time to
conduct through the structure of the
spacecraft to areas we want cool
this high emissivity silicon coating is
applied to layer one and two the two
hottest layers helping them send their
heat back out to space away from the
spacecraft as fast as possible these
design choices are what allow the heat
shield to maintain the massive heat
differential between the hot and cold
side
but blocking heat is just one challenge
that's one of the bigger challenges
along with just designing a deployment
system that does this complicated you
know and necessary unfolding
reliably and correctly
in order to fit inside the fairing of
the ariane 5 rocket the sunshield has to
be folded and stowed before launch
leading to some incredibly complicated
mechanics to ensure it unfolds correctly
when game time arrives
deploying things in space and all is
always difficult but when you're
deploying rigid structure
uh that's generally what us engineers
would call deterministic that's
relatively easy membranes and cables are
almost inherently non-deterministic
and if you want to you know have
describe or illustrate what that means
try pushing on a string
you know the string will move but if i
ask you to determine
the shape that it will assume
you will have a very very hard time
doing that
so to control these almost
non-deterministic things
is a takes a great deal of effort a
great deal of trial and error and even
after we're done getting it you know
getting the design right
the one thing about the sun shield it's
it's almost like a parachute or it's
very similar to a parachute
uh you know the parachute will work
but it's also only as good as the very
very last time you fold it
and you're gonna find out whether you
folded it correctly or not
when you use it
the unfolding process will begin a few
days after launch not too far from earth
starting with relatively simple
mechanisms with the solar panels and
communications antenna deploying the
truly nerve-wracking process begins on
day seven as the spacecraft is coasting
towards l2 there are over 300 single
points of failure in this unfolding
sequence 300 chances for a 10 billion
dollar 25-year project to end
107 pins holding the sun shield together
have to be released on cue to allow the
system of pulleys motors cables bearings
and springs to begin unfurling the sun
shield into its precise complete shape
this process will take three days and
once complete the optical components
will unfold and lock into place
completing the transformation process
but we are most certainly not in the
clear
the likelihood of the tennis court sized
sunshield being struck by micro
meteorites is fairly high and because
this is a thin layer of plastic
stretched out under tension a small tear
caused by an impact could cause a
runaway tear ripping through the whole
sun shield to prevent this rip stop
seams have been molded into the sun
shield which will arrest tears and keep
them confined to a single portion of the
shield without compromising structural
integrity the film has also been
carefully molded with corrugations and
other shapes to stiffen and shape the
shield as needed this passive cooling
system helps tremendously ensuring the
dark side of the telescope is shielded
from the sun's heat keeping its
sensitive heat detecting instruments at
40 degrees kelvin about minus 233
degrees celsius
but parts of the telescope specifically
the mid infrared detection instrument
located here
needs to be even colder to work
correctly it needs to be seven degrees
kelvin
just seven degrees of the absolute
minimum temperature of the universe of
zero degrees kelvin and for this we need
active cooling
the james webb telescope includes an
innovative cryo cooler for this purpose
the challenge in developing this cryo
cooler alone was immense
costing 150 million dollars
getting cold temperatures is just one
small part of the design vibration has
to be eliminated as the tiniest movement
of the telescope could cause massive
blurs in the image as it attempts to
focus on objects billions of light years
away
that means eliminating moving parts
where possible
and when that can't be done incredibly
precise machining and movement is needed
to balance weights as they move
the cooler also needs to use a tiny
amount of electricity as the telescope
only has 2 000 watts of power provided
by its solar array
and it needs to run reliably for years
that means a closed loop cycle with our
refrigerant being continually reused
i found this explanation of the cryo
cooler on nasa's site the pre-cooler
features a two-cylinder horizontally
opposed pump and cools helium gas using
pulse tubes which exchange heat with the
regenerator acoustically
ok horizontally opposed pumps with
carefully balanced pistons that will cut
vibration as the weights balance each
other out but the rest of that
explanation sounds like it came straight
out of a sci-fi novel
a sound wave is just a pressure wave and
pressure and temperature are directly
proportional higher pressure will cause
higher temperature
one way we can take advantage of this is
by creating a standing wave where the
peaks and troughs of the wave are
stationary we can do this in a closed
tube where the resonant frequency of the
tube is determined by the tube's length
here the sound wave will bounce off the
closed end and create a region of
compression and high pressure and
therefore high temperature
this alone isn't terribly useful the
energy and temperature in this system
will stay relatively stable left on its
own
but what if we could extract some of
this heat with each cycle then on each
cycle we could gradually cool the
overall system
to do this we need a way to pass energy
out of the system this is done with a
stack a porous material with air gaps
that allow sound to pass through it
which is placed so that it smoothly
spans both the hot region at the end of
the tube and the cold region in the
center like this
a heat exchanger is then placed on
either end of the stack one for the hot
side and one for the cold the hot heat
exchange will conduct its heat to the
center of the sun shield where it can
radiate out to space while the cold
portion will conduct its heat or lack
thereof to a copper plate attached to
the back of the infrared sensors to cool
them to 6.2 degrees kelvin
this is obviously an extreme
oversimplification
of the actual operation of the pulse
tube cryo cooler
this is just a basic explanation of the
physical phenomenon that allows it to
work
the pulse tube cryo cooler is quite
possibly the most fascinating part of
this spacecraft to me utilizing a simple
physical phenomenon with extreme
precision
allowing those infrared sensors located
in the center of the telescope's
beautiful golden mirror to work
the golden mirrors are the most striking
part of the telescope made of 18
hexagonal segments 6.5 meters in
diameter
so
what's the deal with the design it's
unlike any telescope mirror i have ever
seen the mirror surface itself is
beryllium plated in gold
that's a unique and expensive material
choice
we need the structure of these mirrors
to remain in an extremely precise shape
to reflect light as desired
they can't bend and they can't warp with
temperature changes and they also need
to be extremely lightweight to reduce
launch costs
beryllium is a lightweight metal with an
atomic weight of just four
it's much lighter than silica glass a
more traditional mirror subsurface
material
while being far more capable in dealing
with the cryogenic temperatures the
mirror will operate in keeping its shape
and not contracting so much that it
ruins the carefully shaped curves of the
mirror
while nowhere near as strong as steel
beryllium is much stiffer with a young's
modulus of 300 gigapascals
this means that while beryllium is
easier to break than steel it's harder
to deform before it actually breaks
giving it excellent dimensional
stability on a pound-for-pound basis
beryllium is six times stiffer than
steel
making it the perfect subsurface
material for this mirror
however it is not reflective for that we
need to turn to gold
gold is not the best reflector of
visible light
being particularly poor at reflecting
the lower frequencies of the visible
spectrum giving it its distinctive
golden hue
but critically it is an excellent
reflector of the infrared spectrum while
being very unreactive ensuring the
mirror surface will not tarnish and lose
its shine during its operation
to reflect that light a very thin coat
just 0.1 micron in thickness is coated
over the polished beryllium subsurface
taking just 48.2 grams of gold about the
same weight as a golf ball
a surprisingly small amount for the huge
mirror which has a collecting area about
25 meters squared 5.5 times larger than
hubble's 4.5 meter squared circular
glass mirror
the mirror needs to be massive and to
explain why i asked mike mancell
well i could tell you how much it's
collecting uh first uh we're looking for
uh
uh stars or or stellar objects or things
that are approximately going to be a
nano janski
and to explain what a nanogens gets is
units of bright a unit of brightness
it's very very dim we're looking for the
among the dimmest things there are in
the sky
if i was to put a child's night light
puts out about five watts
put it on the surface of the moon and
look at it from the earth
that source would appear to be 20
nanojanski's
so we're looking for objects that are
120th
as bright as that
to do that you need a big telescope
picture light as as rain coming in if
you want to collect a lot of rain you
make a big wide bucket
well even at the size of our bucket six
meters across
we're only collecting about one photon
per second one particle of light per
second
and to put that in perspective
i'll go out tonight or any night and
look at the brightest star there is in
the sky your eye
is probably collecting about one million
photons per second
from that star so to see these very dim
things the dimmest things there are to
see in the universe
you need a light bucket that's at least
the six meters in diameter
one photon per second really puts things
into perspective
mike and the rest of the team working on
the james webb telescope actually wanted
the mirror to be bigger but the cost of
launching a mirror that size between the
increase in weight and limited space
available inside the ariane 5 fairing
was not cost effective
they maximized the size with the
resources available and incredibly even
though the mirror's collecting surface
is 5.5 times larger than hubble's the
james webmere is 62 percent lighter than
hubble's massive solid glass mirror
that is an astounding weight saving
driven by launch weight requirements to
get the telescope to l2
and the mirror is even programmable
when hubble first began transmitting
images back to earth it became clear
that there was something wrong with the
telescope's optics
instead of the crisp awe-inspiring
images we are all familiar with today
the early images came back blurred
the mirror had been ground down to flat
by a mere 2 000 nanometers 150th the
thickness of a human hair
but that was enough to cause the light
to be focused incorrectly on the
telescope sensors
replacing the mirror was not an option
but hubble was designed to be serviced
throughout its lifetime featuring
modular equipment bays that allowed
older equipment to be removed and
replaced in order to correct the issue
corrective optics were installed into
one of these equipment bays
like a giant pair of glasses for the 1.5
billion telescope
james webb will not be serviceable it's
simply too far away from earth beyond
the range of any space vehicles capable
of carrying humans to services if there
was a problem with the mirrors that
would be game over
but the engineers were not taking
chances this time and have engineered a
system capable of adjusting its focus by
itself
each of the 18 separate mirrors can
contort its shape and adjust its
position relative to the secondary
mirror located in the main mirror's
focal point
the weight saving iso grid rear side of
the beryllium mirrors are assembled with
a system of backplates struts and motors
that can not only adjust the mirror's
rotation but with the center motor and
these struts the mirrors can actually
change their curvature to adjust the
focal point of the mirrors
a feature that could have corrected
hubble's issues from earth once fully
deployed the telescope will begin its
calibration phase with each mirror
adjusting itself until each of the 18
segments have aligned correctly with the
secondary mirror
a 0.74 meter convex mirror which itself
has six motors to adjust its position
these motors and control systems are so
precise that the mirrors can adjust
their positions in steps on the scale of
wavelengths of light creeping closer to
alignment by increments of one-tenth
thousandths the size of a human hair
that is an astoundingly accurate
electro-mechanical system the engineers
of the james webb telescope performed
this calibration test here on earth with
an absolutely massive vacuum chamber
that can be cooled down to the same
temperature that the telescope will
operate at
ensuring proper focus can be achieved
but the job to get a clear image isn't
done with primary and secondary mirror
alignment alone
they focus the light onto the cassegrain
focus which is located inside the aft
optics subsystem
this black protrusion in the middle of
the primary mirror which blocks stray
light from entering the aperture
in the darkness within there are two
more mirrors
one of them being the fine steering
mirror
and this thing is the world's most
expensive image stabilization tool
it is controlled by the fine guiding
system the fine guiding system is locked
onto a guide stair and its job is to
keep that stair in the center of its
field of view
every 64 milliseconds the fine guiding
system will send signals to the attitude
control system to make adjustments to
ensure the telescope stays on target
this attitude control is done with a
combination of six reaction wheels
located inside the spacecraft bus
below the heat shield and with the fine
steering mirror this mirror will
constantly be adjusting itself to ensure
the target of the telescope stays steady
on the sensors minimizing blur
the telescope also has thrusters for
larger position maintenance
191 liters of hydrazine and 95.5 liters
of its oxidizer dinitrogen tetroxide
will be stored inside the spacecraft bus
that will feed 20 different rocket
thrusters scattered around the telescope
there are eight thruster modules two on
each corner of the spacecraft bus to aid
the reaction wheels and spinning the
telescope to point towards points of
interest
these 16 engines will be fed with
hydrazine only a monopropellant reaction
where the hydrazine is passed over a
catalyst causing a highly exothermic
reaction breaking the hydrazine down
into nitrogen hydrogen and ammonia
the other four motors are for orbital
and positional control and require more
power
they will be fed by both hydrazine and
dinitrogen tetroxide this fuel and
oxidizer mixture react hypergolically to
form nitrogen and water hypergolic
meaning they do not need an igniter they
simply ignite on contact with each other
hydrazine is an excellent choice for a
long lasting mission like this the
hypergolic reaction means the motors can
repeatedly and reliably fire without a
point of failure causing issues like an
igniter breaking hydrazine is also
stable for long periods at room
temperature allowing it to be stored
over the expected 10-year life cycle of
the james webb telescope
unfortunately that life cycle is limited
to 10 years precisely because of the
fuel between pointing and orbital
maintenance we will run out of fuel at
some point and nasa currently has no way
of refueling the telescope but rumors
are behind the scenes nasa is looking to
develop the technologies required to
refuel the james webb telescope before
its demise 10 years from now
robots capable of refueling spacecraft
far from earth is an exciting concept
the james webb telescope could end up
teaching us many more fascinating things
beyond the early stages of the universe
it's my hope as an engineer and after
being 25 years on this job
that eventually our telescopes the
really really really big ones of the
future will be built in space
testing james webb
a telescope that's designed to work in
space
has been a very difficult thing to do
on the ground
and i'm hoping that someday we'll be
building these things in space
testing them in space
tweaking them in space
and then deploying them in space that
way
we are on the frontier of a new space
age
and the james webb telescope is a
milestone on our journey towards being a
more capable space-faring society
this is just one of many milestones in
our brief time as a species capable of
escaping our planet's gravity from
building our incredible global
positioning network and sending
satellites to the far reaches of our
solar system to visiting the moon and
building reusable rockets it's never
been more exciting to be an aerospace
enthusiast especially when you can get
access to the curiosity stream and
nebula bundle deal for just 11 59 a year
this holiday deal gets you access to
incredible space documentaries on
curiosity stream for less than a dollar
a month and with that yearly
subscription you will get full access to
our battle of britain series launching
in the new year and our nine-part
logistics of d-day series that is ready
for you to watch right now this discount
will end on the 24th of december so you
have less than a week to avail of this
deal a great stocking filler gift for
the documentary fan in your life while
supporting this channel in the most
effective way possible nebula gives us a
place to experiment in safety without
any worry of alienating our current
audience on youtube or being demonetized
for covering sensitive topics like war
your support there has helped this
channel evolve and grow and we are able
to give you exclusive content like this
as our thanks
many of you will be happy to hear that
we finally released a roku app for
nebula giving you more options on how to
enjoy our ad-free videos the best way to
support this channel is by signing up to
nebula through the nebula and curiosity
bundle deal for just 11.59 a year with
access to both nebula and all the
amazing award-winning documentaries on
curiosity stream like this amazing
series called trajectory that tracks the
scientific milestones of space science
over time you can sign up to this
amazing deal by clicking on this button
on screen right now or if you're looking
for something else to watch right now
you could watch our last video on the
future of supersonic travel or you could
watch real science's latest video on the
insane biology of orcis
you